you're all in the right room I'm not
evil inna Elena's in room one we swapped
I'm Hannes I'm gonna talk to you today
about building IOT backends in our code
of net what I'd like to cover today so
you know what's coming and give you a
brief introduction with all you need to
know about net then I'm gonna explain to
you what the problem domain was that we
were working in when we we did this and
what role I could have not played in
implementing the solution and then I'll
dive into some technical implementation
details so you know how to do this
yourself if you want to get on board and
then I'm gonna put you on your way with
some resources that you can use should
you want to play with our current met
yourself and produce interested I have
stickers so come see me after talk if
you want and I couldn't net sticker to
put on your laptop so what is our
current net in the 70s and when people
were not distracted by smartphones a lot
of research got done and a lot of the
stuff that we are using today was
invented by back then in theory and it
has become possible today to implement
it because we have the processing power
and actor models are no different in the
early 70s Carl Hewitt and Peter Bishop
they wrote the first research paper that
actually talked about implementing
software with a likeness to nature like
things in nature interact with each
other and that's what actors do and
those papers got refined during the rest
of the 70s and the early 80s a lot of
people worked on that and the first
practical implementation was in the 80s
and Ericsson we're talking about the
period where tokus were making money by
doing landline connections and if you
could not make connections you wouldn't
be making money so reliability was a
very very important factor for them but
of course nobody had made an
implementation so they invented their
own programming language which is
Earling and they invented that to build
the axd 301 taco system and their focus
was on being very performant very fault
tolerant distributed concurrent all
these things that we value now and they
managed to get nine nines uptime with
the code base that had about two million
lines of code which is impressive it's
even more impressive if you put that
like in real time because that means
that you will get 31 milliseconds of
downtime per year I don't know about
your codes but I don't achieve that so
yeah if this has been around since the
70s in the 80s
why did we only get it in hire
programming languages later on because
if we look at where our code net comes
from in 2010 there was a implementation
of the actor model on the java java
virtual machine which is Scala and they
actually implemented akka and only in
2013 two people individually from each
other started porting akka to the net
CLR Arin standard and Roger choice and
they started working on that separately
from each other and then they found out
about each other's efforts so they
decided like okay let's take the good
things from your codebase and like takes
the good things from mine and combine it
and make it into one effort and they
actually got permission to call it a
kebab net from the original akka people
on the on the JVM and in 2015 we got the
first production release by now the team
is a lot bigger than the two of them and
it has become very stable there's very
we're very close to getting the 1.4
release which will improve networking
performance so yeah it became a very
very stable effort now what happened in
2015 is that on the.net ecosystem we got
three actor model implementations over
the course of a few months microsoft
opens
source project release which they used
to build the back end for Halo 4 and the
thing with games is you get most of your
revenue the first couple of weeks after
release if your back end cannot keep up
people cannot play if people cannot play
you get bad reviews if you get bad
reviews you don't get sales so they
needed something that they could very
very easily scale and they had all the
processing power because they have a
sure and the backends for office 365
they had the servers but they needed
like the programming on model so they
built or links but in the meanwhile the
azure team was working on the service
fabric and on service fabric you also
have the service fabric reliable actors
and then guys that I just talked to you
about they also released I could net so
why if all of this has been around since
the 70s and the 80s that we only get it
in 2015 that's a question you should ask
yourself now the thing is classic
scaling around that time went through a
bit of a crisis because the web was
booming because of smartphones and IOT
devices and all that sort of stuff and
the fact that you could deploy an app
into the App Store you couldn't predict
how many users you would get so if you
do it like a classic web application you
would start building is a cluster of web
servers and if they couldn't keep up
anymore then you would like increase the
scale if your database cluster and add a
caching cluster and so on and became
really complex and it's really hard to
do if you've tried doing this you know
that there's there's no free lunch and
then the second problem is the evolution
in processors because if you look at
this trend this is basically what
happened in terms of transistors and
clock speed and single thread
performance to the processor landscape
and there is three lines that are really
important to notice is that clock speeds
they have stabilized for over a decade
like we've had three gigahertz
processors for a very very very long
time
and I don't think anybody sells anything
over five gigahertz commercially anyway
so that has stabilized single thread
performance is actually stabilizing as
we speak but there is one line that is
increasing a lot and that is the number
of course you probably have more cores
in your phone right now then you would
used to have in your laptop ten years
ago so that is the number that we want
to exploit if we want to build something
scalable right now the thing is if
you've tried paralyzing code that is no
easy thing to do
who here has tried to manage a thread
pool manually in net or another higher
programming language yeah was that fun
no the problem is always shared state
because as soon and you're always going
to have to share state between threads I
mean otherwise your treads not doing
anything if you have shared state that
means that you will have race conditions
you will need to implement blocking
there could be that locks all this parts
that you're gonna have to do that are
gonna hurt your scalability and if you
look at Amdahl's law he thought about
this this is a graph that shows you the
theoretical speed-up that you can get by
adding more processors in relation to
the amount of code that can be
parallelized
so if you have only 5% of your code that
needs to run in series and all of the
rest of the code can be paralyzed as
much as you want you will never get more
than a 20 times increase in speed so
even if you throw 65,000 processors are
added you will only be able to handle 20
times the workload so if you want to
build something that is really really
really big 90 percent or 95 percent is
not going to be good enough so that's
where the actual actor models try to
help we're gonna try to achieve
a very very very very high degree of
parallelization with stateful systems
because if you have two implants
something that's completely stateless
that's really easy to do if there's no
state you can just paralyze everything
but if you have state it becomes harder
and they do this by doing reactive
patterns and to have also fault
tolerance built in so that if something
crashes not the whole cluster goes down
it's just this one error that occurs and
you keep running and if you know randall
munroe grade book recommend rate so I'm
going to explain how that works and then
the basic building block of the actor
model is of course the actor and an
actor is a very very simple object I'm
gonna show you in code in a second how
that looks but the actor has an inbox
and it's a first-in first-out messaging
inbox and that's the only way you can
talk to an actor you send it messages
and then the messages will get scheduled
on the actor to be processed and your
actor will have all its states and all
its behavior and all its code internal
to the object there is no other way to
communicate with it and when you process
all these messages in order you know
that you're on a single track so you
don't have to write any code to make
sure that it's thread-safe
because every actor will only run on a
single threat or will never be two
messages processing at the same time and
that makes a lot of things a lot easier
so if you look at the most simple actor
you can write this is an untyped actor
it's a class you inherits you implement
from the echo dot net package and you
will have an unwritten
and the Unruh sieve is the method where
all your messages come in you can figure
out what type of message you're getting
and process it this is like the simplest
form of an actor that you can have
right now what is very important about
these messages the messages are simple
classes as well you don't even have to
inherit anything or implement any
interfaces it's just like a basic class
now the thing that you have to pay
attention for is that they have to be
immutable because the academic runtime
does not enforce them to be immutable
but it expects them to be so in theory
and as soon as your message crosses a
machine boundary you no longer have have
that problem because it gets serialized
and deserialize ins and serialize so
then you break the reference that you
have to your object but in theory you
could send a message to another actor
and then keep reference to that object
and as long as you're on the same
machine that is still like a CL are
objects that you can change don't do
that you're gonna have a bad time so
it's very easy to manipulate that but
just don't do it it'll it'll cause all
sorts of problems now in true put they
claim that they can process about fifty
million messages a second on a single
machine I have no reason to doubt that I
can easily get over 1 million messages a
second on my laptop so if you have like
a serious server you can probably
achieve those numbers so how do you do
that with immutable messages you just
make sure that everything only has
getter properties the only tricky part
is every type of collection now you have
the immune system that collection stuff
immutable namespace where you basically
get collections where you cannot add or
remove items anymore so use those in
your messages and you're gonna be fine
and then the most important thing is the
actor system itself because you have all
these actors but something will need to
manage the lifecycle of your actors it
needs to spin them up it needs to
dispatch messages to them it needs to
manage all these inboxes because it
could be that an actor has a full inbox
of messages waiting and it needs to do
all the thread scheduling for you and
that's the thing that we're really happy
about because we don't want to do that
ourselves right there's also a system
eventbus for if you want to do publish
subscribe between actors I'm not gonna
dive into that today but know that it's
there it's basically your big puppet
master right is this is still by far the
best Metallica album ever and if you
disagree you're wrong no an actor system
if you have to create that in code it's
actually really easy and you go actor
system create you give your actor system
a name and that's it now what is
important is if you want to deploy
actors to your actor system you will
always do so true something called props
what are props and props is basically
you could see it as a pointer to the
constructor of your actor you can tell
the actor system how it needs to
instantiate your actor and then the
actor system will do that for you this
makes sure that you will never have a
reference to your actor from the outside
you will have something called an eye
actor ref like this my actor variable
here will be an eye actor reference and
you can use that to talk to your actor
you can send it messages so you just
instantiate an object as a message class
and you do your actor ref don't tell is
exactly how you dispatch a message to
your actor right and then the actor
system will take care of that for you
now actors live in a hierarchy there's
three actors that's always present it's
the root actor the user and the system
actor these are the top level actors the
these are the system actors
below the user 1 that's where you create
your actors the top-level actors are the
ones that are directly under the user
actor and then below that everything
every actor can spawn children as many
as they want now the thing is the only
thing that's really important in this to
remember is that your address is your
place in this tree so this be tree
fellow at the bottom his address is
slash user slash a to slash D tree and
that becomes very important later on
that you can address these actors by
their address now to make sure that if
an exception occurs in this whole actor
hierarchy which are all processing their
messages and to make sure that that
exception stays contained we have a
concept called supervision how many of
you have children yeah right so take
your children to a supermarket who is
responsible you are right if they
up you have to clean up the mess right
that's exactly how that works in an
actor system if you spawn children you
are then responsible for supervising all
the errors that they caused which is
actually a very very flexible concept if
an exception occurs in an actor the
parent will actually have a strategy on
what needs to happen you can choose to
resume which is basically okay that's
not bad just continue or you can restart
the actors like ok we're gonna start
over see what happens and then the
message the inbox of the actor gets
preserved so that's a good thing but the
state is discarded and then you have the
fact like okay yeah that messes
everything up just stop what you're
doing we're gonna figure out something
else and you can do this for only the
failing child or for all the children
this is the most important concept in in
fault tolerance in actor models right
you make sure that
if an exception occurs it occurs
somewhere in the bottom where it doesn't
really affect anything else so if you're
going to do something risky you just
push it on to an actor and then see what
happens now in general if you start
programming in this you're gonna need to
think about your code a little bit
differently you're used to doing object
oriented a lot of that will transfer to
this but the main the main ideas and
everything comes down to this again it's
like you've got to split your workloads
into very very small tasks and you're
gonna make separate actors to process
all these tasks and then you're gonna
send that work to them and you push all
the risks to the bottom because if it
fails there it's very contained and one
thing you need to watch out for is that
you don't create any bubble make actors
if you there is something like
overflowing mailboxes because an actor
runs on a single threat so if you give
it more messages than it can process on
a single trap then you're gonna have an
ever-growing inbox but you can avoid
that by making sure that your message
message flows our models do not have
those there's a whole bunch of design
patterns that go with this basically the
one that I just explained to you is like
you split all the work and you divide it
over your children which is the fan-out
pattern but there's also some proxy
patterns that you would need to use to
avoid faults when you go over Network
boundaries which could happen and then
there's a whole bunch there's a whole
course I think it's a four hour web
course that peda bridge does but a
bridge is the company that was erected
by Erin standard and Roger Johansen they
actually gave production support on
akkad on that you can follow that course
and you will get into all these things
there's just one of them that I didn't
want to withhold which is the character
actor pattern anybody watches Star Trek
here okay what happens in Star Trek if
you have like a guest actor somebody
famous who comes in for like an episode
or two they arrive at a new planet and
they send that game that guy down first
and he dies right well why do they do
this they want to keep their main cast
alive because the main cast is important
to the series you want them to be alive
by the end right but some sometimes for
the storyline somebody has to die so you
get a character actor in they play this
one role they die that's okay because
the series moves on and that's what you
do with actors as well if you know that
you're going to do something risky gonna
go over a network can I go to the
database I don't know you're gonna do
something that might fail you push it
onto a separate actor you just monitor
that for failure and you deal with the
failure or success of that actor but if
that one fails your state is preserved
because your actor did not die this week
all the character actor right you see if
you do a risky operation you spawn a
child you delegate your opera your risky
operation to them and you handle it I
think that's enough information about
actors is that a little bit clearer for
you how that pieces together okay let's
get into our problem domain then do
these look familiar to you that's what
my meters look like in Belgium it's like
electricity gas water now this was
basically what we were working on we
were building a metering backend for
these and their more modern varieties
that did have digital connections but we
could actually implement some optical
readers on these and still get like
these meters to connect to the back end
as well so how did that look in our
connected situation is you will have a
meter in your house we would connect an
IOT device to that that would get the
meter readings from them it would send
it over the Internet
to our back-end and our back-end was
then used to present information on your
smartphone it would have a web portal
where you could configure alerts all
that sort of stuff that was what we were
billing the red part is that what we're
going to be talking about one important
concept to grasp before we dive into
this is the reading versus consumption
problem these devices I'm going to go
back for a second these devices they
have numbers on them
well the number by itself doesn't really
mean anything because you could have
bought the house and there would already
be a meter reading on there what is
important to you is like okay how much
did that reading change regarding to the
last time that I checked that is your
consumption that is the thing that
you're gonna get built for that is the
thing that you're probably gonna care
about not about the number per se so the
blue line would be our meter readings
but then the difference between that and
the previous five minutes
mark is basically what we consumed and
that's the thing that is interesting to
work with so what did we want to do with
these readings we want to store all of
them for all eternity so that we would
have historic usage historic use usage
data for analysis
so we wanted to store all the normalized
values we wanted to be able to plot
graphs on top of that we wanted to
compare time periods and then we wanted
to have alerting on them we did have
some machine learning that would detect
unusual situations not what we're going
to talk about today but we wanted to
present some alerts to the user on their
phones I hate something is happening in
your house that is not correct please go
check usually it's when consumption
exceeded certain thresholds this is
really clear if I want my consumption to
never exceed the red line then at 10:30
I would get an alert on my phone right
what becomes a lot harder is if you look
at a periodic threshold it's like yeah I
don't want to go over a certain line for
the next 20 minutes and then it becomes
a business discussion that you're gonna
need to have because that red line it's
very clear you've been over that red
line for 20 minutes that's very clear
you should trigger a trigger an alert
now the Green Line is a different story
you exceeded it a few times you didn't
exceed it every time block but still you
exceeded it on average
there is no correct answer but that's
the kind of discussions that you're
gonna have to have with your business
when you get into this right so then it
behaves as expected so basically that's
what the part of the the problem that
we're gonna look at today now how does a
kebab net fit into this if you're gonna
build an IOT stake on the.net ecosystem
chances are that you're going to look at
Asia and your typical IOT stack will
have to have a few things and the first
thing is the communication to your
devices somebody has already solved that
problem for you but what you're
basically going to want to do is your
devices will authenticate against your
back end they will send you events so
you will need to be able to accept
messages from your devices you would
have to detect if they are online like
presence detection very important thing
and then you would want to send control
to them turn on the lights set the set
point of your thermostat that sort of
thing
thing right you get all that out of the
box in IOT hub don't write it yourself
we did because we started before IOT hub
existed I would not do it again now next
to that that is how you connect to your
devices but then you're gonna need to
start processing data and store it so
you're gonna have to look at all these
compute components probably gonna look
at at your functions or service fabric
you're probably gonna use some cue
somewhere you server service bus stream
analytics and then you're gonna store it
in various ways if you want to store
lots of bulk data like time stamps bulk
data you could basically dump that into
a blob per device that works really well
because blobs have indexed search so if
you know when the blob started you can
point to a certain location in the blob
and just read some data there that's the
data are gonna need if you need to store
lots of sensor data really cheaply
that's a way to do it but you can use
like cosmos DB or as your sequel
whatever you need and then you still
haven't created any business value yet
then you're gonna need to present that
data in portals and apps and
analytics on the that and machine
learning and all of that so you're gonna
use things like app services service
fabric you're gonna use notification hub
to push your notifications to your
devices you could use power bi to build
some dashboards now not all of this can
be done by accident net
I mean basically the compute and
analytics part is where it would be
useful to use an actor/model because
that's what it's really good at i
wouldn't build a website using our
current net per se it could talk to it
in a backhand but there's no added value
so what our setup looked like is we had
our current net cluster the a cannot net
cluster talked to all of the storage
components that we had and on top of
that we had the web portal that
basically talked to the cluster to
present the data to the user and then on
the device site we had IOT hub talk to
the devices and then you had an event
stream you familiar with IOT hub or
event have a measure
it's basically a string of messages and
you have a pointer and you can move your
own pointer right so you start reading
at a certain point and then you get all
the messages so we had an app service
that had a pointer and that would relay
the messages to the Aqua Net cluster so
this is a pet peeve of mine don't be a
magpie okay you all know about the
magpie like a white bird like shiny
things don't be that developer don't use
a framework because you want to use it
use it because it's appropriate for your
use case so I could not know this useful
if you need to build something that has
lots of state and needs lots of true put
and you want to have a high degree of
parallelization trading systems gaming
backends IOT applications I mean
everything that you want to highly
paralyze that is what it's good for but
it's always going to be part of the
solution so I'm going to show you a few
of the important parts of our actual
implementation of this so that you can
understand how it all pieces together
these are the four things that I'm gonna
explain and I'm gonna then I'm gonna let
you have your lunch
the first tricky thing is if you look
back at this graph you see that the Aqua
Net cluster runs by itself and if you
remember from a few slides ago sending a
message to it was done in process right
you had the actor system and then you
could get an actual reference by
creating it with props but we're not
gonna do that over the network so we
have to run our actor system as a
cluster and the way that we do that is
to use remoting and the funny thing
about this is if you want to talk to an
actor system remotely you create your
own actor system locally because actor
systems can talk to each other and
that's what I cut remote does the cool
thing is this is like 100 percent
transparent so you have an address and
you know that you're gonna talk to an
actor system that lifts somewhere else
you're gonna have your protocol this is
like a URL that you could see in any
protocol right you have a protocol the
name of your actor system the address
where it is on the network and then the
location of your actor right that is
your actor pop now the thing is you can
even create that actor remotely so you
can basically tell it to create that
actor at that location and then the
other actor system will create it for
you now what the funny thing is I talked
to you about these AI actor refs right
the one that you got back when you
created your actors with your props
those objects are completely location
transparent that you can pass them
around so if you have an actor F to a
certain actor you can just pass it over
the network as a message and that one
will get the eye actor F and it can talk
to the actor that it points to even if
it lives somewhere else that's what we
call location transparency and that's
really important in this whole scenario
there are more transports than just TCP
one of the big upgrades in
I cannot net 1.4 that's coming out in a
few weeks they released beta 4 yesterday
I think is that there's gonna be some
performance improvements on the TCP
protocol not that it's slow now it's
just gonna be lots faster when we're
done so what did it look like for us
this is the getting you're getting your
messages to your actor system on the
right you will see the aqua dotnet
cluster that's where all the actors for
our devices live on the left you will
see the app service that reads from the
IOT hub event stream and that the ones
to dispatch all the messages to the
remote actors system and how that works
is you create an actor system in your
client that's your client
actor system and you're gonna have a
bunch of actors there so what I will do
is I will create a proxy actor for every
device identified by its UUID
and I will create that proxy actor and
that proxy actor on startup will talk to
the remote actor system and it will ask
the top-level actor there it will send a
connect message is like hey I'm device
with UUID blah blah blah and that actor
will actually figure out if the device
already exists if it doesn't it creates
it and then it will pass the iecturers
back to the device proxy the reason that
we do this is if this one has an actor
ref in memory everything is a lot faster
you can talk to it by address but then
you use an actor selection and actor
selections are way slower than eye actor
references and from Denham basically any
message that comes in from the event
stream can get relate to that one and
that one can talk to the device actor
directly this is basically how you run
that whole proxy remoting thing and the
fun thing is you can extend your proxies
to detect if the other side is still
present because that will actually get
messages in
and that you can subscribe to if the
message is that it tries to send to the
other side if they fail so then you can
retry and end that sort of stuff what
does that look like in code and this is
a very busy slide I'm really sorry but
the important things are your actors can
have a pre-start minute and that is code
that gets executed before it accepts its
first message and that is very
beneficial because this code here in the
pre-start
it will make that connection to the
other side so what it does is we have
that top-level actor and we define that
as an address and the remotes actor
system is basically the protocol and and
the network address of our remote
hectare system and we talk to it and we
use an actor selection and that doesn't
really matter I told you that extra
extra actor selections are slower than
actor references but this only happens
once per device after startup doesn't
matter if this is a little bit slower
you get an actor selection you can talk
to an actor selection as well by just
using tell and you send the Kinect
device message to the other side and
then the other actor will basically
reply to its sender which is very useful
and that will come here and you will
have the handle device connected message
will come in and you will basically now
have your reference to the other side
that you can talk to now you notice that
we are not using an untyped any actor
anymore but we have a receive actor and
a receive extra is a more strongly typed
version of the actor and basically what
you can do in the constructor you can
have these receive methods for various
message types it looks a lot cleaner for
me as an oo developer this is like it
feels like I'm doing the right thing and
all my functions are single
responsibility so every time this proxy
gets a message it can now just forward
it to the device actor which lives on
the other side and this is a tip that
I'm gonna give you
what I always do is you remember those
props to create actors what I always do
on every actor is I make a static method
that I call create props that map's all
the parameters because you have this
props create and you give it all the
constructor parameters and you see this
constructor parameter maps to that one
now that is in no way strongly typed so
you can do create props and then you
have a programs array and if you
refactor your constructor and you add or
you remove a parameter your compiler is
not gonna break but it does if you do it
like this I make sure that I only
consume the create props and I make sure
that that maps with the constructor at
the top and then if I want to refactor
my constructor I know exactly where am i
code that was used because that will
actually break up on compilation did
that make sense
if I told you that okay good now the top
level lights are on the other side the
devices actor the one that receives that
connect message and has to reply that
basically checks if it's dictionary of
actor references already contains this
UUID if it doesn't it creates it and
then it will just reply with a response
and you can do sender dot tell because
you know your actor is and
single-threaded which means before you
start processing the message a lot of
stuff is set on the execution context of
your actor and every actor class has a
sender property which is basically a
reference to the one who sent you this
message and there's a bunch more you
have like a context there's a whole
bunch of things that you could that you
have available to you on that thread
that is set before the message is
dispatched and because you're the only
one processing it will always work at
one thing is important though an address
needs to be unique in the hierarchy so
if you have our setup like it was you
will need to include your device ID in
the address somehow because otherwise
your addresses are not you
in the hierarchy so that's one thing
that you need to look out for that is
how we got our messages to our akka
cluster the next thing that we need to
think about is how we normalize data
because your business logic is really
easy to reason about you're talking to a
business owners like yeah think about
this alerting situation that is really
easy to reason about but in the real in
real worlds your data will not look like
that so you might want to normalize what
you do and it becomes a lot easier from
my experience if you normalize the data
stream that comes in and then only use
the normalized data downstream it
becomes a lot easier when you know that
there are no gaps that timestamps are
consistent all that sort of stuff these
meters and even the ones that do have
serial ports they sometimes send
gibberish and well if it's like a
message that is corrupt you might detect
it sometimes it's just like a single
number that flips but that might change
your meter reading which means you might
get a huge peak in your graph for
instance it happens these are in no way
perfect devices so I want in my codebase
I always want to deal with that in one
place and if you look at that in a table
and if you have a very consistent
consumption of 60 kilowatt hours every
minute then it would look like this but
you would maybe get measurements at 25
seconds past or this times this
timestamp could drift sometimes these
are very very very low powered CPUs and
you would get a reading every 25 seconds
but it would be 25 seconds since the
last time it finished processing but
because the CPUs are so slow that could
take like half a second so over time you
would drift and that's okay if you fix
that in one place so what we did we
wanted to have like a value every five
exactly like on the 5-minute mark
because that became really easy to
reason about and then we would normalize
the reading and the consumption and it's
simple interpolation that is not really
hard to do so you take that data put it
into a bucket summarize it and then all
the business logic will work on the data
on the right but the biggest problem is
gap filling because these devices they
live at your customer and their internet
connections are not reliable especially
if you're in Australia as we learned
yesterday evening now if you miss a
couple of buckets what do you want to do
with that and that's a business decision
it's not your decision as a developer
because fixing this is really easy but
there is no right answer I thought about
it for like five minutes and there's at
least six ways to solve this and
actually the one that we used was
another one than this or there seven and
you can choose to choose not fill it and
you will have a gap in your graph or you
could like do the diff between the last
blue dot and the first one and just like
put it as one peak value all the
consumption in one bucket it's usually
not what you want because you will
trigger trigger alerts that way yeah you
can put that peak in the beginning of
your time period or at the end or in the
middle you can choose to take that value
and split it evenly and in a graph like
this one that might make sense but if
your device has been offline for three
days splitting it evenly it doesn't make
sense at all because your power
consumption or your water consumption is
not linear so you might like plot it out
over a trend line that's like we take
the value before then the value after
anyway we just plot it on the line even
that is wrong so what we eventually did
is we would look at the same time period
last week and see how the graph evolved
and then build a similar shape with
which amounted to the amount of
consumption that we knew that we had in
our gap that was like the closest
approximation that we could
get to being correct it's still wrong
but it's for our purposes it was okay so
gap-filling is something that you're
gonna have to talk to to your business
and sometimes you're gonna have to
decide to notify your downstream actors
like hey this is gap-fill data because
you might want to decide to maybe not
trigger trigger alerts on capful Dana
right now how does that work if you're
writing code if you receive these meter
readings on your device actor you have a
normalization actor as a child that
takes in all these readings and you just
forwards your incoming meter readings to
your normalization actor that one does
all the mats that you decided to use to
normalize it and then you send
normalized meter readings back up to
your parent & parent is another one of
those properties that is always filled
on the threat of your actor and all the
downstream actors from there on they
will just use the normalize data this is
a very easy setup and it makes the rest
of your actors a lot simpler now another
thing and that we haven't discussed this
yet but you realize that until now we've
always talked about state being
properties on your objects right data
internal to your object and what happens
if you recycle the process all of that
is gone what happens if your actor false
and it asks its parents and it gets
rebooted because of your supervision
strategy the data on that actor is also
gone you can preserve the mailbox you
cannot preserve the state so how do we
deal with that actually there's a
library called ICAP persistence and
instead of implementing the untyped
actor or the types actor you can
basically use the persistent vector and
there's like a persistent type actor as
well basically you give the actor that
you want to persist state from you give
it a persistence ID that needs to be
unique because that's gonna be the key
in your database and then you can call
persists whenever you feel that a state
it's persisting and is basically an
event source system so you are going to
persist events and they will replay a
Pommery start right
you can persist commands you can save
snapshots because you don't want to
replay all events for all eternity you
want to start from like a fixed point in
time and just replay the last bit and
when your actor is created and it is a
persistent actor it will actually query
the database get all the comments that
were persistent out it will restore your
last snapshot it will restore replay all
the commands and you will be in sync
again right you're familiar with the
event sourcing as a concept cool so how
do you do that this is the receive
persistent actor and now you have to
start thinking about the difference
between actual commands and recover
messages because they are different
things I will see on the next slide what
that means for your business logic this
persistent ID has to be unique so we put
the device ID in there and then we will
send every command we'll go to the
handle commands message and then every
recovery will go to the internal handle
message there are some recovery methods
for snapshot and you can basically
because saving a snapshot isn't a sync
method you can get a result from that
operation if it's important to you to
know if your snapshot succeeded or not
it doesn't really matter if you miss a
snapshot in most scenarios because you
will just recover from the previous
snapshot but if it's important to your
logic to know if this if the snapshot
succeeded you can subscribe to these two
the safe success and the safe failure
now if you handle your command you're
going to call the persist method and the
persist method has to two parameters
first is the message that you would like
to persist and the second is the
internal business logic that you would
like to call when the persist is
successful and it does these two things
in sync right so if the persist fails it
will not actually
and handle the internal message and then
your business logic you're gonna write
down here because if you're recovering
from a previous state you don't want to
persist the messages again right you
don't want to have a persist in there
because then you will have this loop of
never-ending persistence and every
hundred messages you can maybe decide to
just make a snapshot what I usually do
is I create a state object for my actor
that includes all the state that I want
to persist makes it a lot easier because
you can just go like save snapshot state
and you don't have to think about which
fields you still need to fill and your
snapshot offer when that restores that
is basically if you you reboot a
persistent actor that's the first thing
that's gonna come in you're gonna get a
snapshot offer if you have snapshots
then it's gonna replay all the messages
from the persisted queue and only then
does it start accepting new messages now
how does that piece into our device
situation remember we want to store all
historic values not just the values that
were working with right now so what we
did is we had a value storage actor
which was a persistent vector with the
mechanisms that I just explained and
that one used to keep a working set of
data that was big enough to handle all
the runtime data all the alerts that we
needed to process all the business logic
but not data for all eternity
so if data would fall outside of that
window it would get relayed one level
down to another actor that would you
basically save it to permanent storage
so that we could later re-query it back
but it wouldn't have to get rebuilt
every time the actor system rebooted we
just want to have the working set it is
enough to do our operations we didn't
want to get all data for all eternity
back up to our value store ejector right
because that's important we wanted to
have a restart behavior because in the
real world you're gonna like build new
features and you're gonna need to read
which usually means that you need to
reboot your acai cluster so you need to
get all that state back up and running
after you redeploy
a new version of your code and get back
up and running as quickly as you can so
recreating your actors is not really
that hard you query the database for the
actors that are supposed to be Darren
you just spawn children and they will
all query the persistence database for
there snapshots and their events now
that works really well because they're
all single table selects and they all
query by key so it's really snap fast
you can restore a million actors in no
time the problem is if you make all your
actors persistent your database
connection is going to become extremely
chatty and that will become your
bottleneck so our strategy wants to have
one actor that basically persisted all
the data per device and all the rest of
the actors if they need to restore their
state they would actually query that
actor and if you remember first we get
our snapshot then we get our events and
only then do we start accepting messages
from other actors so if other actors
send a message to query the state that
they need the persistent actor will have
rebuilt and will have that state in
memory and it can respond with it to the
other actors by minimizing this you can
basically improve the scaling of your
restart behavior after you deploy so we
did that we had a value storage actor
and the normalization actor needs data
to work with
because it needs to know what the
previous message was that it got so
which will just ask the value storage
actor for that up on store start up all
the alerts actors will do the same thing
and that's how you basically make that
work and if you piece all this together
in a good way you can basically get up
to running really quickly after a
restart
that's the stuff that I wanted to talk
to you about today now if you want to
move forward or further from this
there's still so much stuff that I did
not talk about the first thing is if you
are going to run this in production
you're gonna need to deal with a CAD
configuration you want to gonna need to
configure your cluster you're gonna use
Holcomb for that the human optimized
configuration object notation I think it
is you're gonna need to set up your
clustering didn't cover that today
either you're gonna probably want to use
logging and dependency injection at some
point and you're gonna want to monitor
your production environment data bridge
has a product for that it's called
Phobos it's really good so those are the
things that we didn't cover today but if
you want to run at a production you're
gonna need all this if you want to start
learning about Aqua Net
there is a bootcamp bipedal bridge which
is free you can just go to github you
can do it by yourself it's self-paced
learning it's really good
it gets you acquainted with all the
concepts of iconic map and also on
Pluralsight you can find some pretty
good stuff the peda bridge blog is a
goldmine of information every new
feature that they built they blog about
with code samples and everything so most
of the stuff you can find on there and
then there's the online trainings that I
talked to you about earlier and they are
paid they're quite affordable I had most
value from that by first trying the
above tree things and like building a
system until I had real questions that I
couldn't solve myself and then it's
really worth doing it because they do it
in a webcast with a small group and you
can ask questions directly to the people
who build the framework so you're gonna
get real answers as well also for your
deployment I covered a little bit how we
rebuild our data on the other side of
the deployment you're also going to need
to take care of a few things you're
gonna need to stop that app service I
pause it so that it doesn't keep sending
messages to your cluster you're gonna
need to have your cluster finish
processing then you can stop here to us
or redeploy it and then resume
the event stream and if you do this
right you will not lose any data you can
redeploy your application without any
problems
so in conclusion first you need to check
if your problem problem domain is fit
for actors if it is you're gonna have to
decide which part of it you're gonna use
excellent at 4:00 you have to design
your actor hierarchies appropriately
think about persistence think about
bottlenecks think about fault tolerance
which risky operations you're gonna do
we're normalizing your data will help a
lot if you work with IOT devices and
you're gonna have to think about the
whole deployment and recycle process
because that will become a deal
this was my talk for today my name is
Hannes I work for access in Belgium
that's my twitter handle and my ICQ
number make ICQ grade again you can find
a complete solution with all the stuff
that we talked about on github check
that out there's a lot more in there
than we cover today so feel free to look
at that ask me some questions over
Twitter whatever tonight we're going to
do this fun thing in a pub not too far
from here there will be 12 people doing
funny talks if you haven't bought your
ticket yet I encourage you to do so food
and drinks are included with your ticket
it's gonna be fun ask me some questions
that's that's a good question and the
the question is how do you deploy your
actors do you deploy that as a monolith
your actor system needs to know about
the Assemblies that contain your actors
because otherwise it cannot instantiate
them because you will hand it
constructor pointers through props you
can spread them over as many assemblies
as you want but your actor system needs
to have references to all those
assemblies in runtime right so whether
you do that by just deploying a separate
assembly and then when you start your
actors system you scan them through
reflection that would work just as well
but usually it's easier to have indeed
one monolithic deployment for your actor
system that has all the assemblies for
all the actors to all the notes exactly
yes
I put that into in the question is how
do you run that remoting part we
deployed that as an app service which
also has a reference it has to have a
reference to the akka libraries and it
has to have a reference to your message
classes because it needs to send those
it doesn't need to have a reference to
all the actors that live on the other
side because it will only get actor
references from them we did an app
service because that's easy on Asscher
and we didn't need to manage a server
for that we can basically do it in any
type of process that you want so if our
website would also have a remoting actor
system in it so our asp.net application
would have a static instance for the
remoting actor system to talk to the
cluster to get data to present to the
user so basically your you'll start
building these small remoting actor
systems with the stuff that you need to
talk to your big cluster and those go
inside the net process that that needs
to talk to it but it could be anything
from a console app to full-blown web
application doesn't really matter if it
runs on that you can talk to it okay the
question is how does the state work in
an academic cluster basically if you
have a cluster all the notes talk to
each other through remoting in the
background as well but you don't need to
manage that yourselves because inside
the cluster addressing is transparent
you don't need to know which note the
actor lives on you will provide your
actor classes with a chart key and the
chart key needs to be unique and based
on the chart key your your actual actors
will be put on a certain node so you
have some control over where your actors
go through the chart key but you have to
remember that your
Sharkey needs to say stay the same when
you like recycle the actor and create a
new instance so don't use the built-in
get hash code or anything to create a
short key for your actors because you're
gonna have a really bad time it needs to
be consistent between between
instantiations but that's yeah I could
go into that and do more depth but it
will take us a long time see me
afterwards if you have more questions
about that y'all ready for lunch now
okay
[Applause]